Brian,
this doesn't have a connection.
Did you plug it in?
Oh,
okay.
Hold on.
When your wife was
Wifi is jacked,
people are asking why do you guys have
an opening song?
And then after the opening song then you
play more music.
What kind of Shit is that?
And you're right.
It's fucking ridiculous.
So shows you take us.
I can't believe anybody's even listening
to this point.
This is the most ghetto podcast on the
internet.
The most fun to do though.
And this is a Mashup Brian,
who's the Mesh out?
I believe it's party Ben.
It might be girl talk.
I don't know.
You know what man?
I used to not be a big fan of podcasts
until I heard this Voodoo child z mix
and I was like God damn.
Okay.
You did something there.
You know like a lot of times I'll listen
to podcasts and one or to a mashup
rather.
And I'm like this isn't that
interesting.
It's kind of that every now and then
they didn't fucking make something super
cool.
Just kill it.
Yeah.
It's like,
should they shouldn't think would go
together like chicken and Waffles,
Bam.
Yeah.
You know there is a Jay z Lincoln Park
Mashup that was just dirty.
Yeah.
It didn't feel like a whole album of
that.
Yeah.
I love when Shit like that happens.
I love when artists get together like
that and create something fucking nutty.
We were talking about this before the
podcast and it's,
you know,
total retard,
hippy talk.
But what the fuck is music and why?
What does it do?
Why does it just get in man?
Because way we're talking to is going to
introduce him eventually.
This is my friend Chris.
What's going on?
Chris is a,
he's a writer.
He writes for the blog.
What is it?
Warrior.
Poet Dot taught us to us then and what
is it.us,
man.
I'm looking to take over the world
eventually,
but I'm starting with the US.
[inaudible]
dot com is currently unavailable.
So yeah,
I couldn't get Joe Rogan.com.
The dude who owns it as,
as he's a nice guy.
He's a real estate guy,
but he,
he goes,
just occurred to me to more famous.
You get the more.
This is worth it.
I was like,
oh,
all right.
Derek,
come up buying the twitter dude who was
holding down your a?
Yeah,
but I got it back from twitter.
Twitter gave it up,
but this dude's his name's Joe Rogan and
he's older than me.
So respect to him.
It's got to go to him more than it is to
me.
Uh,
you know,
and I was willing to buy it.
But when after you said that,
it was like,
get out of here,
the more famous you get,
the more initiative worth.
Come on,
man.
What,
what are you 12?
Just tell me what you want.
Can we talk through this?
More family feel that I can hold onto
it.
You feel grit and restaurant,
except you have to be able to buy it for
it to be valuable in some matter.
You can find me now.
It's Google Joe Rogan.net.
If you can't,
it's probably good.
It probably filters out a bunch of
idiots.
Yeah.
Because if you can't type.net
instead of.com,
she'd give up that quick.
You know,
I couldn't find it.
I don't want you find the people who put
the.com
in the google search bar instead of the
url to.
Yeah,
sure.
Brian knows about that.
I do that all the time.
What happens when that,
when you do that,
you porn shows up in the aftermath using
a flashlight.
Is that really what happens?
Porn shows up if you put a dollar every
time I put anything I,
I'm on fucking directly.
I think.
I think that's called a virus or I just
need to clear my cache because it
seriously,
everything that comes up on my toolbar
know,
just been beaten it furiously lately.
Brian,
if you don't know,
ladies and gentlemen,
Brian had a very lust filled short term
relationship which filled with passion
and the loss of fluids.
And then,
uh,
as,
as quickly as the storm came into town,
storm left and I have kids.
Now I have a kid.
Now he's got a kid from the
relationship.
Just.
So here's,
here's lesson number one.
Children.
Anyone under 30 that I'm talking to you
right now,
listen to me.
Do not get a dog with a chick ever.
Don't do it unless you guys have kids.
Don't get a dog and if you do,
do it good.
Get nutty.
And if you do,
do it,
go right to the pet store.
Fuck what they say.
Just go against all the rules and
getting one of those dogs that will go
to the pet.
So don't support puppy mills,
man.
Hope those pet stores go under.
Go to the fucking pound or go to a good
breeder.
I got one of my dogs from a breeder,
man,
I am not,
there's nothing wrong with breeders.
People talk shit about breeders,
but if the guy's a passionate breeder
and really breeds dogs because he wants
like a good beat.
My dog is awesome dude.
And one of the reasons why he's awesome
is because his dad was awesome.
His Dad was one of the security dogs on
fear factor.
We had um,
like bite people in these big crazy
bites,
suits and his dad whose dog was so cool.
He was just chill,
hanging out with everybody.
Not Do she do the other dogs,
it was just the sweetest dog come over
to hey man,
what's going on?
Meanwhile he's this giant,
massive and I'm like,
what a great dog.
Like he's so friendly and such a
difference.
Genuinely affectionate,
like come up and rub against you and
love it when you rub his head.
Like how crazy is his dogs get like this
perfect personality with this guy.
Won't let his douchebags breed you.
Just anytime he goes,
I love them,
I take care of them,
but no breeding you,
you fuck.
And he takes and he takes all the Douche
bags out.
So he's done this for like 20
generations.
So his dogs are like the coolest dogs.
Like I come over his house,
he's got these big fucking massive.
So it's like the chicks,
like a buck 30 and the males like a buck
50 and they'd come up to me like,
okay,
these are lions.
These are digitally small lions that I'm
just assuming you have control over.
You know,
I'm walking in your house and I'm
trusting my balls and my legs.
I'm trusting all my soft tissue to these
monsters that you have under your
control.
The dogs couldn't have been more chill.
Just like,
hey,
how you doing?
Come not,
not like checking you out.
Like what's up bitch?
She put the fuck you doing around here,
not sniffing you.
All Aggro.
Like some of them will disrespect you
with a sniff and that's,
that's like letting you know pitch.
I'm just going to Sniffy Dick Right now.
It's just like Dick,
you know,
they're,
they're going agora one,
your man,
they're pulling some Alpha male shit.
You've got to step in and stop them from
doing that.
These dogs were nothing like that,
man.
These dogs were so cool.
They just had this air about them.
Like,
hi,
hi.
Come on.
In.
Meanwhile they would do bite work,
like he would have these dudes in a suit
and they would hold them back and they
let the dog loose and it was like a meat
cannon.
Like you shot a side of beef of this
dude's arm that they would just latch
onto the guy and bring him down.
I'm like,
what a crazy thing.
You've engineered this dog that will
respond to your.
Every command is super intelligent and
is gigantic and can mimic the primal
attack map and then shut it off and shut
it right off the superfund to physically
exactly what he's designed to do and do
that.
Impressed the.
That was the most impressive thing to me
when we're on fear factors,
what people have done with dog breeding
and dog training,
like dogs that really know their shit.
They're impressive man.
That's impressive.
They have it locked down.
They're giving them treats and they're
setting them up and they'd given them
their affection or given them the
recognition for what they'd done.
These dogs will do anything.
They'll do whatever the fuck you say.
No,
that's pretty nuts that we figured out a
way to do that.
Yeah.
I always think it's kind of funny that
people will.
You know,
I totally love and respect people,
rescuing animals.
I think that's a beautiful thing that
people do and then there's the other
people who will buy like a budget
animal,
which is definitely coming from a bad
place for like 100 bucks.
Sometimes people do the dog and the dog.
Yeah,
but you know,
they expect great results.
It's like there's a place where they had
like $25 tattoos.
You're going to have this for a long
time,
like make a good investment.
But some people just say it's a dog.
What could be wrong with it?
I've had,
I've had a bunch of dogs with like I had
this bulldog.
He's had to have a bunch of operations.
Brian just killed my mind.
Sorry.
He's got a.
he's got a hip dysplasia so he had to
get both his arms operated and there was
like six grand man.
It was serious money.
So it was like $18,000
I think for both of his arms.
He had have one operation and then had
have one like a while later and then
they were talking about replacing his
back hips and I'm like,
listen,
this dog is lazy as fuck.
You don't have to do that.
People dog just likes to chill like you
don't have to like,
yeah,
he walks around with a bit of a limp,
but he seems happy.
He might be in a little pain,
but most of the time he's just chilling,
you know,
he's not a running dog.
He's a bulldog.
He's just gonna.
Relax,
you know,
like,
yeah,
he's fucked up.
You don't have to give a metal hips.
All right.
Just let them be fucked up.
But that's a dog that was given to me,
if that,
if that there was a situation as a
situation,
if they wasn't,
I would have never wanted to get a dog
like that.
I wouldn't want.
I would look for dogs that have a
genetic propensity for hip dysplasia and
stuff like that.
And you gotta you gotta think,
man,
it's,
it's wonderful to love a dog and take
care of them.
But you're adopting a giant bag of
fucking problems with some animals.
You know,
if you get them from a good breeder,
you know what the fuck you're getting.
Yeah.
We're uh,
we bought a big savannah cat is going to
be almost a 30 pound cat.
Told me about that.
That's insane.
And you feed this thing like chicken
wings and chicken bones and it just,
it,
it just sits there.
And it will stock it and then just
pounce and then I'll grab it and its
mouth and throw it up in the air.
And Paul it before it gets down to the
ground.
Just savage?
Yeah.
Trusted with you.
Does it ever get dickie with you totally
know.
Definitely Alpha mailed it to destroy
things?
No,
he doesn't have that crazy cat instinct
where he's going to rip it up.
Do you have um,
posts for him or something?
We do have some posts.
And do you use,
does he use those?
Yes,
he does.
So he doesn't defy,
you know,
I get this little motherfucker,
this little motherfucker.
I got this little cat name Oliver and
he's a ragdoll and he's a sweet cat.
He's super friendly.
Super Sweet.
Yeah.
Loves coming up.
But if you tell him to get the fuck out
of here,
he's going to keep coming back.
Right.
It's like,
you know,
he's going to prove a point.
Like he'll,
he'll come into my library,
has a carpet in and I don't like him
licking his asshole on my white carpet.
You know,
get the fuck out of here at your ass.
Dingleberry's are worse than me.
I'm looking there as well.
Whatever.
Just take care of that right away.
He's trimmed.
I trimmed them,
we turn them for the summer because he's
a fluffy cat and it gets hot as fuck out
here.
So,
uh,
anyway,
so he,
you know,
he's looking at his hands hall and this
white carpet.
I'm like,
get the fuck out of here dude.
Come on.
You got to go.
I'm being nice about it.
I pushed.
Pick them up.
I take them out.
Thank you.
Bye.
I go back in.
I'm rearranging my shit.
I turned back and he's licking his
asshole again.
Same spot.
It's like,
what?
You can't lick your asshole over there.
He wanted to walk back to the exact.
No,
this is where I want to be.
Like,
no,
I'm the one who decides where I want to
be.
I want to be right here.
I picked him up.
I put them out of that room four fucking
times,
but finally shut the door.
I had to shut the door.
I had to give up.
Will Cock sucker.
He tests me,
but he's a little tiny cat,
you know,
if it was like a big survival,
that's what they're called.
Yeah.
Well it's bred from service.
So they call them Savannah's when they
get,
you know,
one generation removed.
So it's a serval mix with a domestic
serve will mixed with the domestic.
But the breeder,
I got them from.
They keep,
they've been doing it so long.
It's mostly savannah.
Savannah made exactly is a survival.
It's this wild look in mini Cheetah with
really long.
So wild animal.
Holy Wild.
They don't train those at all.
No.
Those are,
those are,
those are just gone.
I mean they live.
I mean there's pictures from the
breeder,
the servers with the children and stuff
like that.
Like that.
They hang out.
All right.
There was a fear factor show that we did
once and it was in this really rural
area,
really rural,
you know,
like these people were like living out.
There was no one out there.
And um,
one woman had a dog that got fucked by a
coyote and a hal is half coyote,
half dog puppies.
It was a trip food.
It was a trip,
they were all huddled together because
it was freezing cold,
bunch of the cast or the crew rather
took them home as,
as pets because everybody was so
heartbroken because it was really cold
outside.
We were filming in the winter and we're
up in like this really,
you know,
high altitude area,
it's cold as fuck.
And there's these puppies,
a huddled up together like shaken and
they're half coyote.
Mad.
Crazy dog got fucked by some murder
beast from the woods.
You know,
when a dog gets fucked by a coyote,
that's kind of be some trippy shit.
Got to be an early.
Those hyenas people use those dogs.
You know?
I wonder if though,
a wonderful dog fucks coyote if that,
if,
if a coyote fucks a dog because that's
what it is.
Usually.
Probably.
I bet it's on dogs.
Fucking coyote is one of those big.
I bet it's a man or mastiffs could
fucking.
I think you'd kill it.
I think it'd kill it,
but yeah,
I think it would have a war they would
go to.
It wouldn't,
but a male gets to fuck a dog.
Yeah.
Males can fuck the dogs.
That's so creepy,
man.
Yeah.
That's like how wonderful dogs can go
back to regular dogs after that,
but they just fucked because you ever
seen a coyote.
His mouth,
when they open their jaws,
dude,
there's like rows of teeth,
like a crocodile.
That shit goes back.
Like the first time I saw a coyote on I
was like,
Whoa,
hold on.
Like you start thinking their dogs and
then you see a coyote yard.
You're like,
you've got like 20 extra teeth.
You fuck.
Scary.
Creepy fucking murderers sneaking in and
fucking your dog.
There's this dude that runs down lake
and Austin,
which is a big bike,
big jogging trail.
He has three wolves and he just pretends
that they're.
That they're not.
Well,
they're beautiful creatures,
but that's a little.
A little iffy.
Yeah.
I have a friend who has one.
He has one in the fucking thing.
Got Out and killed a gang of goats.
Killed,
like got out of his.
He has like a ranch and it got from his
ranch and went into the neighbor's ranch
and just started at Jack in their
animals.
Just fuck it up.
Everything a little too much.
Blood orgy just went over there that you
found a pen that was filled with goats.
So we jumped into this pen and start
carrying these goats.
A partner.
It was a big one,
hundred 6,170
pounds just ripping them apart and I'm
like,
Bro,
you don't have control of this fucking
thing man.
Like you gotta be careful.
So what does he do?
He moves to Hollywood,
brings his wolf.
Three of them,
three of them.
This douchebag living in the Hollywood
hills.
This things out killing deer and shit.
I heard wolves aren't even for home
invasion either.
Like if you come in the home,
they're not territorially protected
because they have those wide range.
It's not like other dogs so immersed in
a burglar murder can come in your home
and do whatever and then one bolt,
but if it threatens you apparently than
the willful,
it'll protect you.
It will protect you.
Yeah.
You're his buddy,
but you're not his dad.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's the difference here is buddy.
It's like,
you know,
if your roommate is getting attacked,
you're going to jump in.
That's not like if your son was getting
attacked,
okay.
You know,
or you know,
if your father was getting attacked
rather,
and that's how dogs are.
Dogs look at you like you're a dad with
a wolf.
He just like,
what's up man?
He's got fucking with.
You will have like,
Yo,
get that shit outta here.
The Wolf is not like you can't come over
the wolf's.
Not like,
who the fuck are you?
Let me check you out and make sure
you're okay.
The Wolf's like,
bitch,
I know you.
Okay,
what are you going to do to make stupid?
That's how the wolf looks at you.
They will not threatened by you.
And he's like,
oh,
are you being nice?
Okay,
good.
Whatever.
I got teeth,
look at his teeth.
I'll fucking kill you dude.
They're not worried about your last
mile.
Yeah,
they don't just listen to you.
It's totally different situation.
It's like for the most part,
you're probably going to be okay in the
not going to kill anybody,
but will's of chill.
People will kill people.
There's a woman got attacked by wolves
recently,
I think it was in Alaska.
I'm not sure where it was,
but a woman got attacked and killed by
wolves.
So it's very rare.
And the last time it happened I was like
the 19 fifties or some shit.
But.
So what.
So what happened?
You know,
if,
if there was,
if there was only like one monster,
uh,
you know,
a fucking Goblin ate some Old Lady's
head once in 18,
12.
That would be the most haunted woods for
the history of time.
He'd be like,
that thing is real and it's out there
and we'll wolves are for fucking sure.
Real alright.
They,
how will you could see them.
You can watch documentaries on them.
If you go through Wyoming,
you're going to see him.
You know what I'm saying?
Or was it Wyoming?
Were werewolves that Wyoming?
Are they North Dakota for sure.
Like yellowstone.
Those are real animals,
man.
And they'll jack you.
And they're smart people.
Forget the mythical basis for that mean
wolves were real enemies.
I mean the expression keep the wolves in
the hills and our women in our beds with
real babies.
You were toasting to that daily,
you know,
back in the days when it happened.
Did they just wise up to our hose gun
situation and just like back off with
all that shit.
I think they got,
they got trappers just,
you know,
decimated the population.
Yeah.
Is that what it is?
And then the population is so small now.
They don't feel that the strength to
fuck with people,
right?
Yeah.
They will fuck up your crops or your
cattle though if you have cows or if you
have any animals,
they will fuck them up.
Man.
Them and mountain lions.
I was,
I was a kid once and I was reading this
comic book and it was a.
I used to read a lot of creepy and
eerie.
Do you remember those comic books?
Do you remember those at all?
Creepy and eerie were like these really
cool comic books that were like black
and white,
like really cool illustrations.
It was all like monster stories and one
of them was about this werewolf that was
a sneaking into these,
uh,
God,
these people that sheep and they were
living in the old west or some shit and
had sheep and the Werewolf would sneak
into their pen and kill all the sheep,
you know,
and then the guy goes out there and he
gets attacked by this werewolf.
And I'm like,
wow.
Crazy.
Would that be if Werewolf was out there
sneaking people's pens and killing all
the animals?
And I thought about it,
Mike.
Just Cheetahs.
Cheetahs do do that.
Mountain lions do do that all the time.
They got a real point.
If you live anywhere near mountain line
and you have animals in your yard,
you got to read that.
Those are game.
They're going to just hop over that
fence and kill them and drag them in the
woods.
Why is it,
why is a wolf man any scarier than that?
I don't know.
Maybe because it couldn't have sex with
you.
The wolf man.
It does make the twilight movies,
that's for sure.
Oh yeah,
those guys technically Werewolf.
So you know,
because they just become a wolf,
you know what I'm saying?
Then they don't become a werewolf.
They've become a wolf.
Like that's Kinda Gay.
Like you know what I'm saying?
Like if you're going to take the time to
more be something cool and new American
Werewolf in London type hybrid shit.
Just be a dog team who have killed that
whole thing now after teen wolf to me
like,
oh,
it's a werewolf guy.
Wolf.
Kill Them.
Fucking Michael J.
Fox is not scary or that did twilight
killed a few for vampires.
Vampires are already killed for a time
ago.
If you think vampires are killed,
go watch Gary Oldman.
Do Dracula.
That's what I'm saying though.
But then also watched the million other
TV shows and fucking knockoffs.
Totally.
But if Gary Oldman came out today with
the New Dracula,
he could rock that shit and you'd be
believing in vampires again.
But now both man,
not too much done.
I think he's done.
I think that last one with Venetia del
Toro that killed it for me.
I'm a wolfpack fan,
bro.
And I couldn't do it.
Shit.
We've talked about this too many times
on the podcasts.
I have Wolfman fetishes.
I've some crazy fucking werewolf thing.
Man,
I don't know what it is.
Ever since I was a little kid.
Loved Werewolf movies.
Just like the idea that some sketches.
You were drawn werewolves.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
When I was a little kid,
even before high school,
a lot of them are like from when I was
12 and 13,
I'm fucked up.
Tap into something primal and Joe Rogen
some fucking.
Pardon me.
That's why I moved to the woods,
man.
There's some part of me that wants to be
out with that.
Has Anybody Seen Joe Rogan on a full
moon and why is he tweeting at 6:00
AM?
It's really sad because I can't live in
the jungle if I could live in the
jungle.
I live in the jungle,
but there's no jungle in America.
So I choose the woods.
I really would like to be just living
around animals and shit.
Well,
it's got to represent some primal part
of all of us.
You know there's something,
there's some energy I think that you
sound so hippy,
faggy bullshit.
So true man.
It's like certain energy when you're
around these animals.
Like one of the people that I lived near
up there was this crazy yoga lady,
very nice lady,
but crazy yoga lady and I was talking to
her about like mountain lions.
I'm like,
listen,
how do you.
How do you guys deal with the fact
there's mountain lions?
Because there's a fucking corner store
up there that had a sign that if you get
attacked by a bear,
you should play dead and if you're
attacked by a mountain lion,
you should fight back.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
You have strategies to deal with
different monsters jacking you.
You're going to play dead by a bear is
biting the fuck out of you.
Really?
You're really gonna do that.
Are you going to be able to do that?
Holy Shit.
So I said,
how do you deal with this?
How do you deal with the fact that you
are around these,
these beasts?
She goes,
I just let them all in.
When I walked through the woods,
I let them know that I'm here among you.
I'm no threat.
I love,
I love you and I love them and I just
walked through and I've never had a
problem like,
bitch,
you've been so lucky.
Zigged,
when you could have zagged,
you could have walked right onto a
mother.
Cougar protected are young.
You could have fucked up and walked into
a fucking grizzly bear and he could have
been with its cobs and freaked out and
decided to eat your face.
You got lucky.
You see all.
You see all those documentaries hang out
with these predators long enough.
Why do people think that they are better
than dear?
Why do you think that if there's love in
nature,
why does it really?
It's all love.
Why does nature let this murderous
cougar snap this deers fucking neck and
suck the blood out and then eat its guts
first?
Because that's what they do.
They go God's first cause they don't eat
grass.
Then they get their vegetation by eating
the guts of the things that kill,
but it wouldn't happen to you.
Why would it happen to the deer and not
to you?
Just you really get thanked.
The universe gives a fuck if you're
around a Predator and it wants to eat
and it looks at you and says,
I think I ate one of these back in the
nineties.
I'll try it again.
It was good.
Yeah.
I only get a hiker once every 10 years,
but fuck it.
Yeah.
They got that Muesli in their system.
Yeah,
Dude,
they'll jack you.
Especially when they get used to it.
Like that's a the.
There's an area I talked about in my
act,
an area in India called the cinder bands
and they have a real problem with tigers
there because the congress have gotten
used to eating people.
The tsunamis typhoons rather.
They wash a lot of bodies into the
river.
A lot of people drowned musical with
fucking villagers.
Man.
These people are really poor.
They're living in shacks on the river in
India and the Tigers eat the bodies that
drown and so they get a taste of human
flesh and they just started jacking
people.
Just Jack and people go through the
article anywhere,
Bro.
There's videos on Youtube and look this
up folks,
if you're,
if you're at home or when you get home,
you got to check out Sunderbans Tigers
because there's a bunch of cool
documentaries online and one of them,
these poor fox,
these guys are census takers,
so they have to find out how many of
these murderous monsters are out there
in the tall grass,
in the fucking tall grass out on a boat.
So what did this guy,
this guy has a rifle and he's got a
helmet on.
Okay.
And the helmet has a mask on the back of
the head because tigers like to sneak up
behind you and jack you.
They don't want you to see them coming.
They just want a jacket.
So these guys were wearing helmets to
protect themselves from getting jacked
by monsters and they have a mask with a
fucking face on the back of the head
with a tigers.
Figured it out after a while that it was
just a face.
So they started jacking guys from the
back.
Anyway,
even though they have these face on,
a bunch of dudes in the census,
takers get killed by tigers with fucking
masks on,
so now they're fucked.
These things can swim,
so they have to make sure that the boat
has an engine so they can swim faster
than the tiger can.
They can run 50 miles an hour and
they've killed 300,000
people in the last 200 years.
Since then you'd think that someone
would take up the challenge and be like,
all right,
tigers were smarter,
dude.
People are like,
you know,
hey,
they're a part of nature.
They're part of miniature.
Some regards there,
right?
I mean,
what makes us that much better?
Because we have the guns.
This is ridiculous.
We don't need them around.
It's so stupid.
Kill them all.
What are you crazy?
The people in India should be.
We are worried about the extinction of
the Tigers.
You shouldn't be worried.
You should be worried about your fucking
murder.
Murderers master that lives in the
jungle.
Yeah,
you've got to keep it alive.
It's your God.
Are you crazy?
Are you fucking that attached to these
animals that want to kill people?
Good.
Guide them down,
man.
Gun the more.
Put human masks on the back of the
Tigers and really confused everything.
Yeah,
that's what you're gonna do.
But I going to find the tiger and put
a basket on it.
How dare you just suck it up.
Did you try to trick the Tigers that
we're trying to.
What I'm saying?
Look confused everything,
you know,
there'll be people with tiger maps in
the back of their heads and tigers with
human mass.
If you could transfer human
consciousness into anything,
if you could transfer human
consciousness into,
um,
a,
like an animal just to see what it'd be
like,
how dope would it be to be able to
download your fucking brain into a
tiger's body and just live it?
Move in the,
run it shit.
You're fucking insane.
Would that be man?
If you could just control the body of a
tiger with a human mind?
Fuck other tigers.
Damn.
How crazy would that feel?
Right?
You know,
oh my God,
fuck this.
This is even when she freaks out,
you got this.
You know,
will allow it to intimidate you even
though it's a tiger and you've got your
dick inside of her.
You have no fear in full control of this
thing.
Last for 20 seconds,
just loads into her.
Just shoot tiger loads into.
That would be insane,
man.
I would think though,
if I had to choose,
I would take eagle.
I would like to be an eagle.
That would be the dopest thing ever.
Yeah,
because equals get to because jack fish,
bro.
Fucking national animal for a reason.
Have some respect.
You know the Turkey.
The Turkey was supposed to be our
national animal.
Really?
Benjamin Franklin was putting forward
this.
The Turkeys.
Turkeys.
The smartest bird that would have made
us less do see Canada,
they have a maple leaf.
They're all chill up there.
We're going to fucking kill her bird.
We eat once a year.
An Eagle Turkey.
If,
if we didn't have the eagle,
maybe we wouldn't be so douchey because
the ego is such a douchey animal.
Just like,
bitch,
why would you want an eagle?
First of all?
Because Eagles don't give a fuck about
anybody.
You ever looked into an eagles eyes.
That's like the pits of hell.
They don't give a fuck about you if
you're holding them and feeding them
everyday and they were a little little
thing on your arm and you get shot in
the head with a howitzer,
they'll go,
well I guess I'm not hanging out here
anymore.
There's fly away.
They don't get sad.
They don't feel bad.
Those birds of prayer trip,
there was a hawk that landed on our
ranch and we knew something was off with
it because it was just hanging around
the house.
So my parents were like,
all right,
we got to try and bring it in.
We got to try and get it to the bed or
something.
Whoa.
So they sent me with a kitchen where
they sure have bullets.
Yeah,
exactly.
With the kitchen glove and a little
piece of steak yet though.
So I'm like going very slowly,
like looking at this hawk and the.
I like thinking of the options.
Do I do I run like what happened?
But you know,
it turned out that it was the
domesticated hawk,
so I was able to give it to meet and
then it dug it and then it hopped on the
kitchen glove that's brought it into the
house they rescued it.
Does it for,
for that to have happened?
I don't know.
I'm glad I found out because we asked
him like,
have you done this before?
Yeah,
we do have time on your glove,
Bro.
What animal would you be?
Shut the fuck up.
Brian's on a date,
Chris.
And that was right there with you.
Oh actually we have to know the answer
to one of those things.
If someone asks you,
what's your favorite color?
Like,
Yo,
shut up Dick.
Meanwhile,
it is a valid question.
Maybe you have a reason why you're into
violet.
I'm into purple,
Fuchsia,
car,
radical hidden camera on trademarks.
I'm kind of pink.
Is it?
Did really good for trademark it.
Boy.
Hobby Vasquez.
He fights in pink shorts.
He wears.
He wears pink.
A pink little fucking tighties when he.
When he fights,
he fights fights to strikeforce.
A bad motherfucker.
We fights for WC.
Excuse me,
he was fighting for a.
You want to King of the cage title?
He Won.
He's fought in Japan and one over there.
He always wears pink shorts.
He doesn't give a fuck.
No one wants to be close up to see if
the stars are clearing out.
It's just pink shorts and a package.
There's another dude that,
dude,
I'm the fuck is his name.
Tim Kennedy.
Tim Kennedy always trains with pink
gloves.
He wears these big fucking girly looking
pink gloves.
But he's like,
he's like,
when you're a fierce motherfucker you
can wear pink.
Right?
I can totally make sense.
You know,
how did the color get to be so
disparaged?
Why the traditional girl color?
I mean,
what is if people gave it to girls on
the,
on the baby shower day,
you know,
so it was just try why they end up pink
all over the world.
There's not like,
are they in the like in Transylvania,
a little girls in a black little,
little,
little goth girls make the big colorful
little girls the prettiest color.
You know,
I think if you're,
you don't want red because that's like
an eagle pass my faggot test piece.
The prettiest sparkly pink.
Get to keep the name pink.
You know the singer pink is nobody else
been pink.
How does that mean?
That bitch got the best name for a
chick.
Could have ever like,
what's the girliest should ever gangster
all girls love pink deserves it.
But she does deserve it.
She's,
she's a bad ass,
you know that uh,
I wrote a whole blog about watching her
perform at the emmy's that I watched.
I watched her perform and I was like,
you gotta be fucking shitting me.
Like that was just sheer brilliance in
coordination with perfect singing and
just just so in tune with the crowd and
had everyone mesmerized.
It was fucking beyond.
Yeah.
But I'm just shocked that nobody got
paint before.
I mean,
she's not old.
It's not like she got there first like
nobody thought to call themselves pink.
It seems like there probably was.
I bet some fucking dummy that just
didn't trademark it.
Right?
Yeah.
Way before that whole Charlie Chaplin
was pink.
Once she don't,
she don't.
She heard about me,
she heard about me.
I created my name,
my name.
There's always when,
whenever someone famous gets famous,
there's always someone that thinks that
the,
that happens all the time.
Oh,
he's got my whole act.
That's my whole routine.
I was doing that in the catskills.
Everything
he knows.
I've heard that story so many times that
a guy makes it and then you go,
Oh,
you know that guy made it.
But there was a guy back in like
Michigan who was scared to leave town,
but he was the guy he learned from that
guy like you,
like there's like creamer.
This is a real Kramer Kramer from
Seinfeld,
but there's a real dude.
He calls himself the real Kramer and he
gives tours of New York.
He was the guy that burst through doors,
like universally acknowledged as the guy
who inspired that character.
So he somehow or another,
they let them capitalize on it and gives
tours and shit,
which has got to be so twisted.
Yeah.
And Boring.
Maybe not man.
Maybe for him it's like the shit,
you know,
maybe if he was a dentist he'd be bored
and maybe if I,
my dentist had his job,
he'd be terrified.
Maybe.
Maybe the dentist themselves mean who
knows what,
if he made really supposed to be Kramer,
the guy's got to be very eccentric.
Right.
I mean if that's really the guy who
they,
they.
Yeah.
You know,
after you.
Fuck what,
what does that guy do now?
I've seen him in randomly and placements
and appearances.
Railing recently.
You're talking about Kramer?
Yeah,
the real one.
Yeah.
What the fuck's his knees about to go on
somehow.
Forgot how.
Come on.
Michael Richards.
Thanks.
He just attacked the photographer the
other day.
Did he take it together?
I guess he punched him and stuff.
That's one of the worst predicaments in
the history of the media for an actor,
for an actor to have done that was one
of the worst predicaments,
you know,
that's like,
like people have caught people with
hookers,
like hugh grant got busted with hookers
and you know,
and Alec Baldwin yelled at his kid.
That's all good.
But you know,
it's not that bad.
No.
Right.
The world out here as a nigger,
there's,
look,
we have a nigger,
he says Joe,
and I mean,
I know it.
I know what he was trying to do.
Spoil alert.
What is trying to spoil spoiling,
right?
What he was trying to do is say
something completely shocking and
somehow another rescue himself from a
bad situation where he was bombing and
he wanted to figure out how to get them
out to hurt them.
How to shop,
how to let them know that he didn't give
a fuck.
You know,
like,
Oh,
you're going to fuck with my show.
Think it's okay.
Oh you
think because I'm on Seinfeld,
I won't get crazy at you.
Oh look,
here's a nigger.
Look,
we have some niggers,
you know.
And everybody was like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
It's shocking.
But what's most shocking to me is that
that word still works.
It's one of the few still freak out
though has magic in it still has that
ability to affect people.
It's interesting.
It's amazing.
The only one left.
The other one I think couldn't have done
it.
I have a whole bit about the three magic
words,
love,
Nigger,
and count.
Those are the three words are the three
magic words that have the word love
always has way more power than than any
other words you could string together.
Like I care about you so much.
I think about you all day.
I just.
I don't know what it is.
I just want him around you.
I want to be affectionate and do you
love me?
You have to say it.
You have to say I love you.
I love.
Oh well,
we're in.
We're in the house.
We all go in and that's magic word
number one.
Can't sort of.
But that's getting used a lot.
It gets tossed,
especially in a walmart cards now,
so I don't think it's hallmark using cut
and cards in England.
They can't all the time.
Everything's caught this fucking cunt.
Fucking dudes.
Yeah.
This fucking cunt over here.
They,
they start it up so much that it's like
this fucking dude.
It's like they're saying,
dude are going to be left with two
words,
but.
But niggers still very,
very controversial.
You know,
and just even the joke of my act,
I would say that even saying it's a word
like I'm not even calling anybody yet,
we're just saying the word and you're
like candyman candyman character.
It is like that.
It's like you're in your,
you're,
you're saying and in contention is going
to bring violence your way.
Like you,
you are,
you are using a bad word.
You're not even calling anybody
anything.
You just saying that this word exists.
And in,
in,
in incanting it and saying it out loud,
you know,
you run the risk of violence.
That's amazing.
That's amazing that it's 2010 and we
think that's okay.
I think it's one of the few words were,
I can't even hear my own voice saying
[inaudible].
I don't think I've had the courage to
voice.
It's just a word.
I say it all the time and you fucking
tell me how you do.
Tell me what you say.
Fucking nigger.
Whoa.
That was offensive.
Brian.
I thought you were going to say n word,
n word.
That's even more offensive pictures.
Feel free to swear in front of you.
You might be wearing a wire,
you dirty n word,
but she's not really one,
so it's not bad.
You know,
if she was really a black then it would
feel bad,
but she's white.
Could be white.
You could be a white nigger.
I think that's an a song somewhere.
I'm sure it is.
What's a wigger no nigger brand?
Stop saying that.
It's uncomfortable for everyone.
We just weirded out half.
Wouldn't have America ridiculous as
100,000
people this thing.
Listen folks,
so they're just words.
That's the point.
It's a ridiculous point that's been
argued throughout time.
It shouldn't,
shouldn't be still going on.
It shouldn't be.
It should always be your intent.
It should always be like whenever you're
in any environment where you're not
allowed to say certain words,
you make that environment at least 20
percent bullshit at all times.
Any work environment that you're at,
nobody's really totally being
themselves.
Everybody has to have this stupid guard
up because you can't say company can't
say fuck,
and you can't say shit and you can't
talk honestly about how you feel about
things.
No,
you're in a professional working
environment except that flashlight.
I'll have to accept that.
Especially Chris by the way works at
flashlights.
Chris is,
what is your exact job over there was
your vp of marketing and business that
he's a.
The reason why we made the connection
and uh,
he's also the reason why they have an
avatar flashlight.
Let me say this correct.
Just as a correction.
This is not,
I say I was the alien pussy realities.
We blue.
We actually launched this two years ago
with we totally,
which is our space.
We pushed this out two years ago.
It was just a space vagina.
We put some girls and some blue lipstick
and.
Oh,
so this was.
But it just happens that they're super
hot.
And here's the,
that you didn't even make it look like a
vagina at all.
I like how you did that.
Like doubleclick is a whole bunch of
thought of this.
The mold inside is like a bunch of
eggshells.
Greg's every site has a,
the bowl has like different ribs inside.
The urban myth,
is that an urban myth,
the razor blade in the vagina from
Vietnam,
is that an urban myth?
I've never been do that.
You never heard that?
Now hookers would take these back in
Vietnam was like when I was a kid in
high school.
When you're growing up in Boston,
back in Vietnam,
I heard what they did.
They took a razor blades and they put
them up the girl's vagina and he'd fuck
them and cut your Dick and half.
You never heard that before?
I hung out with a bad crowd.
If you heard of the rape condoms.
I've heard of those.
Yeah.
They have little spikes that stick.
They shove it in the girl.
The girl shoves it inside of her like a
Tampon.
Okay.
And it's basically like an interior
lining for her vagina that's filled with
barbs.
Like fucking with fish hook type deals.
So these guys,
they rape a lot apparently in Africa.
It's like a serious,
serious problem.
Super in right now.
It's like one out of three women in
Africa has been raped.
Certain areas of Africa,
and this is one of the areas where
they're pushing these rape condoms,
like those guys are going to kill now.
Now it's not just going to be raped,
it's going to be rape and murder.
You know,
if a guy sticks his dick inside you and
comes out bloody and covered with fish
hooks,
chances are I might hit you,
right?
Yeah.
He's raping you an asshole that he would
so give you a moment,
but it was such an asshole that he would
rape you.
You don't think he'll kill you if you
cut his dick up,
guys,
a piece of shit,
you know he's not going to go you,
you were really shouldn't have raped
you.
I got fish hooks on my dick.
I deserve it.
Yeah.
No,
he's going to attack you,
right?
I would
assume.
Yeah.
I just thought I was actually out there
in Africa,
Kenya,
Tanzania,
Uganda,
and out with some of the tribes when we
were working with some of the men out
there to try and actually instill
traditional martial arts into them so
that they could see some kind of martial
arts in the tribesmen.
Yeah,
and some of the inner inner city to slum
kids because really they have a whole
generation of fathers that are gone from
aids,
just no father figures so they have no
nothing else to really go to.
So they get picked up by gangs,
they get picked up by these war parties
and then they get turned into little
killer.
So what we trying to do is show them
some kind of paternal discipline and
show them that they can be strong and
powerful without having to be in a gang.
And it was a really cool program and it
worked,
but it's fucking intense out there,
man.
Really intense.
We ended up having to stop the program
because civil war broke out in Kenya and
it was just too nutty to keep doing it.
Damn it was.
It was pretty crazy over there teaching
them martial arts.
Yup.
Wow.
Very true.
Like traditional stylized,
you know,
we weren't going into MMA ground and
pound.
She's like discipline karate type
through the Kata and definitely speaking
to them and they.
I mean they dug it.
I know it's kind of interesting that
Africa is not known for martial arts,
you know,
it's like Africa is the cradle of
civilization,
right?
That's where humans emanated from.
But really martial arts didn't really
pick up until they got to like Asia.
I mean there was other martial arts are
developed in other countries,
but for whatever reason I think it's
because Africa was so fucked up.
They just went straight to weapons.
Like,
what are we doing?
Karate Chop.
Give me a gun,
another gun,
give me a pointy stick,
man.
Give me some shit.
I gotta stab some fucking animals with
some hyenas trying to eat my kids.
All right.
You can't just,
you know,
fucking box of like in Ireland how many
tiny man in Ireland,
you know,
what do they have to worry about?
Deer gets into your yard.
You know what I'm saying?
They had time to beat the fuck out of
each other.
Whiskey bottle.
They didn't even bother learning mma.
I didn't even bother with take downs or
leg kicks or anything like that.
Like,
ah,
this is good enough.
Just here's our hands.
We don't need to get crazy with the
knees.
Come on a flattery,
elbows and against the rules.
That's why you hit me with that.
We're not trying to kill each other.
Then in Africa they're like,
fuck you.
They're going right for pointy sticks to
your chest.
Poison Darts and shit.
Blow guns.
Yeah.
They're just trying to.
They're trying to jack you.
The exception is the Greco Roman style
wrestling with some of the tribes out.
Really good.
Greco and Africa.
Some of the tribes.
That's how.
That's what determines the Alpha and the
tribe.
Really.
All kinds of crazy rituals like they
have good technique.
Do you think you could take their back?
Yeah,
dude,
no way.
No way you can get them to get on top.
Sweep his ass.
Got No baby all tearing web regard.
You Ain't know.
You know about my lockdown popping up
and down.
All the sudden he's choked out.
She could have gone on your bitch.
You got a problem.
You've got a deep problem.
It got with shit and his loin cloth.
So what kind of wrestling and they do.
Well,
it's just like,
you know,
like Greco Roman,
Nicole,
do they understand under hooks hook.
So what kind of throws throws that are
like judo throws,
throws,
throws.
I mean you like an all American
restaurant.
I'm rolling Jack All.
I mean they don't have the nutrition and
the training and eating bugs and shit.
Then I go for you Greco bugs that are
good for your regular drinking some
stuff out the goat blood.
Have you,
you know,
we were talking about this on the show
before,
but in Africa,
trip panning and when you cut a hole
into the top of the head,
have you ever seen that?
No.
Dude,
some tribes in Africa,
the gnarliest shit to their bodies and
I've always tried to figure out what
that is.
We're where,
where,
where's that coming from?
But one of them is trapping t r e p a n
and what it means cutting a hole through
the skull and exposing the brain.
And this one guy had done it 20 times.
Antiseptic conditions?
No.
Yeah,
they're doing it with coconut shells and
shit.
Fucking cut your head open with a sharp
rock.
And I'm not joking,
they are using rocks and shit,
carving,
no,
no anesthetic whatsoever.
Carving into dude skulls.
And then the women in Surrey who cut the
hole in their lip and they put plates in
and the bigger the plate,
the more cows you're worth when you get
married.
Like what is that about?
What is all those?
Those are tough to figure out.
The ones that are on vacation,
they did a lot of that one that's easier
to figure out.
But I think it's maybe the worst is the
clutter ectomies are done by the
masseuse.
Traditional math.
I mean just them,
right?
More bad and it's just know.
And then once,
you know,
once they do that,
like sex is just never pleasurable.
So I mean it's,
you know,
they're trying to do it,
do it because they're haters,
they're haters.
They can't,
they have no game and they want to
control these chicks for life.
And then the chick turns 22 wises up be
like,
dude,
you fucking smell.
I'm not into this relationship.
I'm going to get some good Dick.
Right?
And she tries to leave and to my
property.
And then they have problems,
you know,
it's a bunch of haters,
man.
It's all those faggots and won't let
chicks dance.
All those dudes who want to put chips in
Burkas and shit,
but your eyes,
you know,
they want them to walk around like
they're inside of a trashcan looking
through a slot.
I'll totally insecurity.
There's little faggots,
bitch ass people living in the middle of
nowhere for sure.
If it's the dumbest place in the world
because it's the first place.
I always say that,
that the Middle East is basically they
like the townies of the world because
that is where written language was
created.
I mean the Middle East is responsible
for so many firsts.
You know,
Mesopotamia Babylonia,
where Iraq is ancient Sumerian or they
had the first written language,
the first agriculture,
the first government,
the first astrology,
the first astronomy.
I mean they had a lot of,
a lot of first,
there was a brilliant,
brilliant place.
I mean so much.
So much development,
but everybody,
like in all good places,
they got tired of the Douche bags and he
moved and everybody's spread out.
Civilization spread out across the
country.
It's just like America.
If you go the east coast,
you get a lot of holdouts.
That's what it is.
A lot of stubborn people that go,
I fucking like in here,
fuck everybody else and what they really
are is the grandchildren and children of
fucking savages.
People in Ireland and Poland and
England,
that that life over there sucked so much
cock that they were willing to get in a
boat for months and come to them
someplace,
didn't even know what the fuck it was,
and suddenly they get there and then
they huddle up and they try to figure
out this new place and fight off the
fucking Indians.
Do whatever they have to do to make a
business and get everybody's smart
goals.
There's got to be someplace better than
this.
Let's get the fuck out of here.
And they started traveling west.
Devote your vital energy to something
besides bear survival.
Yeah,
so the VAT is the civilization
beginning.
Assume Sumir and that is Iraq and that
is the Middle East,
the middle.
That's why the Middle East is so fucked
up.
That's where there's such haters over
there,
you know,
I have,
I have a theory that I don't think has
been explored very much,
but it seems like in the desert areas of
the world,
they're very patriarchal dominated,
you know,
and then you get to the coast land,
you get to the jungles,
they have a lot more matriarchal
societies that have a lot more respect
for women and the religions or appear
different.
Something about that dry,
arid landscape.
And of course,
you know,
the major desert religions,
Judaism,
Christianity,
Islam has really taken hold there.
But for whatever reason,
that kind of patriarchal dominance that
occurs out there and those
different.
Yeah,
it's a hard life.
It demands hard,
hard living,
you know,
you have to make,
you got to be.
And you also have to realize that they
had this hard radical ideology thousands
and thousands of years ago and a hard
radical ideologies.
It's very difficult to break without a
revolution.
It doesn't sort of evolve,
you know,
if their ideology about like,
and I don't know how recent it's been
that they've been so strict with women
with the glitter ectomies and with the
Burkas and I mean how,
how recent has that been?
I mean it's still going on there,
right?
But I mean when did it start?
I mean,
how it is it,
is it something that's been going on for
hundreds and thousands of these?
100?
I don't know.
When you have a situation where there's
a lot of fear and a lot of religious
fanaticism,
it's really hard to change because
everybody's scared.
Well,
even the females for the clitoral
ectomies,
some of them feel like they can't become
a woman until they get it.
It's so ingrained.
So if they make it illegal,
what's,
it's actually forcing some women
underground to get them done and even
worse conditions than the flint rock and
a chisel or whatever
done.
So it's a,
it's a nightmare.
I mean,
you really got to attack it with
education,
you know?
I mean that's the only real option.
It's a,
it's one of those things where I think
about,
you know,
there's certain,
certain levels of fear when it gets,
when fear gets ingrained into a culture
and when it's control and that's what a
lot of that is a lot of this,
the controlling of lemon with the
clothing and the dancing and you know,
to try to prevent other men from fucking
them and all that craziness.
Right.
When,
when that should get a hold of a
culture,
it's very hard to get it out.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it takes like a new person or a
person.
Sure.
Yeah,
sure.
Absolutely.
But at least a culture or a person
rather than responsible for themselves.
Like people can wake up and go,
Hey,
I'm a douche bag.
I need to snap out of this.
It's very difficult for a culture to
wake up and go,
hey,
we're fucked up.
You know,
look what we're doing overseas.
Look at were pretending that this is
going on and we're making billions and
we've got all these fucking dummies that
are listening to us.
We can do better.
Right.
It's very rare that a culture wakes up,
we're a government wakes up or any large
group,
but a person can wake up.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
I think the best thing to do would be to
put Internet kiosks fucking everywhere
or just put that in satellite Internet.
Just get them out there and have them
watch spice girls.
Like at that point,
you know,
they're going to say a quitter and kind
of do that with the laptops you have.
You seen those things as like,
are they getting into.
They're like throwing them in,
but they.
Yeah,
they definitely need some big
inoculation of the retardation they've
gone through for decades and hundreds
and thousands of years.
You know,
they need something to get them to
evolve.
When you get like people that are just
so wacky about a certain ideology to the
point where there is so nutty that
you're not even allowed to draw their
main dude.
No.
Yeah.
Think how crazy that is.
You can't draw their main guy or they'll
kill you.
Why do we tolerate this?
Why does anyone tolerate that?
That is absolutely crazy.
Yeah.
Like,
it's not saying no one saying that
Mohammed doesn't exist or never did
exist,
or he's not a prophet.
He might very well be,
I'm,
I am completely uneducated to that
matter,
but you're telling me that you can't
draw them.
Come on,
that's silly.
One of the tenants,
I had a great philosophy instructor when
I was going to school and one of the
tenants that he thought he was
philosophy of religion,
a specialist,
and he said,
any God that should be worship should be
worthy of worship.
You know,
so if you're a god in someone's drawing
you and you're going to Mike them,
I mean that dude isn't worthy of
followers that smite.
Right?
But it's because it was fighting because
they feel it's an offense to God right
now.
Like if someone's drawing you,
you're not going to get pissed.
So does that mean that you're better
than God?
It can't be.
You can't have a system where you know
the god isn't worthy of worship and
being as good as another man.
And this was my,
my thought is that all of this is seem.
It seems so archaic and ridiculous.
It seems so several thousand years ago,
it's amazing that this kind of ideology
is allowed to live through this age of
information like deep into the two
thousands.
So that's.
That's fascinating.
It's fascinating.
Yeah,
it is.
I think there's a real grain of truth at
the bottom of all these religions says
I'm beautiful things.
I mean,
I'm sure in the Koran,
you know,
I'm not as familiar as I am with some of
the other works,
but I've seen a little bit,
here's beautiful passages,
spiritual,
and really powerfully beautiful passages
and all that.
But then,
you know,
men get in there and they're able to
utilize that as a mechanism of power to
wield more power over other people.
It just gets kinda twisted.
What's the origin of it all?
I mean,
if it isn't the word of God,
what is it?
Is it smart people who figure some
things out and somehow or another figure
out how to tell it to people and those
people tell it to each other for
thousands of years and then it
eventually gets written down and by that
point it's become fables and the words
have been twisted and things have gotten
strange and the translations are off the
memories off,
you know,
I mean if you're dealing with something
as big as the Bible,
how many hundreds of pages that it's a
lot.
It's a lot.
So you do try to like say it is a spoken
word thing for like a thousand years and
then they wrote it down.
It was a while and they had a council to
decide,
you know,
it was like an editing where they
decided which now this goes in.
How about the fucking New Testament,
the new testament that even better than
that,
there were candidates for the new
testament.
They just threw out there,
like the editor just recently redid it.
Oh,
the region is.
Yeah.
They have like a newer,
newer tests.
Yeah.
I was just talking to Jesus and shit and
he got some old notes.
We've got some old Tupac tapes and Jesus
is like Tupac.
They're redoing his words,
talking snake sheet with a bunch of
apostles that willing to and all that.
I don't care if we know Jesus.
They chose
words that fitted their fitted their
agenda.
Yeah.
Well that was constantine.
That was one constant team was
controlling Rome.
He's.
He was a smart dude.
He realized he needed a rope people up
with one universal religion.
It couldn't be pagan
that at that point though,
the slave class had really outnumbered,
you know,
the other classes.
So he was,
you know,
he says it came to him in a dream or
whatever,
but I think he was trying to survive the
Christianity spread in the lower
classes.
I mean they idealize that theory that
they were going to go to heaven and all
these rich people who are putting them
to work and doing shitty stuff to him,
they were going to go to hell.
So it took off and then he was like,
oh shit.
Almost our entire country is slaves.
I'm a Christian.
Like Bam,
I had a dream,
you know,
and,
and then that's what,
that's what did it,
you know,
he says it came to him in a dream,
but really I think it was survival.
The Christians were just taken over that
it was just too many in that lower class
versus the patricians who were well
outnumbered at that point.
That's fascinating.
So it was a survival move more than
control move.
I think so at that point,
the adoption of Christianity,
it was like he saw the flood,
you know,
he saw the tide's going and he was going
to either get trampled by it or he was
gonna go with.
Wouldn't you have loved to been in that
war meeting?
Yeah,
for real.
All right,
well how are we going to handle this?
I go,
we got some shit.
Some shit is going down.
This is what people.
They would pitchforks and torches and
shit.
Yeah.
Feeding him to the lions was just so mad
at that point.
Let's tell him.
We found Jesus.
I liked that sound.
We found God.
I'm fucking.
I'm born again.
I don't know about y'all.
Are you born again?
I'm totally bored again.
We can still keep everything going as
usual.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
We bring them in.
We're going to have to include them,
but they're not going to kill us.
Okay.
We're good.
We're born again.
History has changed and he didn't even
become a Christian until right before he
died.
Yeah.
You know,
right.
Wasn't he baptized before he died?
The timing for
a long time in a while.
I mean,
he didn't start leading,
tucking my fucking head in the water.
You got to do it.
They don't believe you unless you do it.
Fucking kitten.
The water,
the water sucks.
It's cold.
You got to do their thing.
Get in the water is on point is you
posted a video about him,
but I've read all of his books.
Is John Shelby spong.
Um,
why Christianity must change or die?
I think you actually posted a youtube
video.
I'm sure it did.
Yeah.
And uh,
he's a preacher who were Kinda is
commenting and very devout Christian
who's commenting on,
you know,
the way Christianity has gone.
And second book is why Christianity must
change or die,
and it's really a poignant book for
anybody interested in.
He was super fascinating.
He was like,
we're on the control business.
This is all the control.
But he was like so upfront about it,
like his whole entire career that he had
brutally honest.
His first book goes through different
passages and basically attacks the
fundamentalist position of Christianity
and says,
look,
you know,
this doesn't make sense.
This was a book.
It was a guidebook.
You know,
there's lots of stuff that doesn't make
a lot of sense in here anymore.
You know,
let's go through this,
let's get rid of this.
And then a second book philosophically
talks about how the evolution and
Christianity needs to be in order for
that religion to survive.
And I think ultimately it will.
I think it's happening like the fire and
brimstone that used to be,
you know,
that Bosch paintings of people just
getting ripped apart.
And if you go to El Duomo in Florence,
you look up at the ceiling and there's
demons with these big,
giant,
big giant.
Wouldn't flaming staff shoving it in
people's asses?
It's like shoving one in,
some girl's pussy in.
You're in this church,
beautiful church and you're like,
what the fuck is up here?
Like ill Duomo,
Duomo.
It's the center church in the middle of
Florence.
Climb up this fucking bananas.
Might have to see them.
I mean I've been there.
Do they have.
They must have the photos.
Yeah,
for sure.
Sure.
So what is the story behind all that?
Well,
I mean at that point,
I mean there were pushing the.
Well it was for sodomy and adultery and
that was the crimes being punished,
but they would be punished by the Duomo.
It's you.
I think it might be ill since it's Italy
and then d,
u o,
m o it's in Italy.
Those crazy Italian.
But I mean just,
just not emad.
Italians are so nuts,
man.
I'm Italian.
I grew up with.
But it's because there are so savage
that they're always riddled with guilt.
Yeah.
They're just so fucking staring.
The leftover Romans,
man,
that's real shit.
Where's the photos of the dragons in the
assholes and shit.
So it's going to be the interior of the
dome.
The dome need to see this so beautiful
fucking building shit.
Stunning.
I mean it's stunning.
They need some dope ass architecture.
I did.
They were on point.
Not Amazing.
Isn't that amazing that if like if you
look at like the Vatican,
you know,
and looking like a lot of the shit from
like the like all the shit that Davinci
painted,
like the Sistine Chapel and stuff like
no one does anything like that these
days.
Some of the sculptures.
I looked at some of the work by this
artist named Bernini and I sat this one
and it was a,
it was a lady sitting on the pillows,
the name a name a while Bernini actually
did the ones that were like Daphne and
Apollo and the rape of [inaudible] 70
and just to look at how they.
He was able to sculpt someone's fingers
digging into someone's flesh.
Like Haiti's is digging into perceptive.
He's into her side,
like grabbing the side of it and you
cannot believe that it's marble.
I mean just the way that he makes it
like flashy and lifelike.
Canova did the same thing with this lady
reclining on a pillow,
just sculpting sheets out of,
out of marble that looked like they're,
you know,
you could fluff them in the breeze just
incredibly you.
It's all this stuff just passed on
through generation after generation of
learning how to work with stone and
carve and.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
That'll never be duplicated.
Yeah.
It's like no,
just way too lazy carbon shit.
Fuck all the weaknesses and the marble
and envisioning what could come out of
it.
But we'll do some crazy shit.
Like walk through the Amazon will do
some shit.
Like I'm going to be the first guy like
Douche bag.
Do you know you can take a boat and it's
like a few hours you go all around.
Well you know what's even crazier than
walking through the Amazon.
Have you seen the documentary?
Big River Man.
The dude who swam the Amazon bods,
he swam the Amazon.
Oh,
this one will be easy to bring.
It goes.
It is a big river man.com.
And see that dude is not.
So he's from like a rounded die.
Well he,
he does pretty much take 65 days,
right.
So it's this documentary of this guy and
he started swimming because he had this
alcoholic father and his father would
come home and try and beat him.
He's in eastern Europe,
try and beat them.
So you figure it out.
They figured out if he went in the
river,
his dad wouldn't follow them and so you
just swim and his dad would chase him
along the riverside one.
And so eventually he learned to be this
stamina,
endurance swimmer,
but he got all fucked in the head,
you know,
and so he goes out and he swam all of
the world's biggest rivers and so it
goes out on the Amazon and I just
thought it's happened to catch this late
night and I was just amazed and he
doesn't do it.
Like a normal swimmer would like take
their protein and do that.
He's like getting them to throw bottles
of wine in the water and whiskey.
He comes off,
he drinks two bottles of wine and he's
not even in shape.
He's like,
he's kind of like Chubby,
you know?
And,
and he gets there,
but then around day 14,
you know all the parents,
he's drinking the water from the Amazon,
so all the sites get him.
He has an onboard doctor and he's like
shocking himself with electroshock
therapy to kill the parasites and he's
like screaming with stuff and like
batteries attached to them.
It's not easy.
But then around the 40th day,
the last you ever hear from him in the
documentary,
he goes,
I'm crossing into the fourth dimension
now,
and he just fucking gone at that point,
just gone.
And then say he'll like wake up early in
the morning and swim away from the boat
and they won't know where he is
now.
Like pointing their light out and trying
to find him.
They see him naked on some river bank
looking at driftwood just because he was
just fucked to begin with.
Or was it all the parasites?
I think it's the parasites and just not
taking care of himself.
Exhaustion.
He so sunburned.
He asked to wear this mask.
He looks like silence of the lambs.
This mask covering his face.
Holy Shit.
It's nutty.
Big River man is the name of it.
Martin strehle I believe is his name
had.
It's funny.
There's some motherfuckers.
It is a broad spectrum of human beings.
It's broad.
Yeah.
You know,
just when you think you've got people
completely figured out,
you'll find some new one online.
You'll see some new shit.
I guess when he was swimming the
Yangtze,
it was so dirty and some of the
industrial areas that he had to have
nightly blood transfusions from a nurse
on the boat,
just new blood in blood out and he just
kept swimming.
Pictures of that swim or just insane.
You know,
he wants to swim all of the biggest
rivers of the world.
What is it about people doing dangerous
shit that they don't have to do?
It's one thing that if you get thrown
into the Amazon,
you have to figure out a way to swim,
to stay alive and make it to the shore
and then get back to safety.
I survived in the woods.
Yeah.
I started a fire with rocks.
I know how to get back and I got back
and I made it.
That's an excellent story,
but when you thrust yourself into that
situation,
like that's not a game,
that's a river.
Well,
I think that is that it's not the
survival instinct that is propagated
this species.
It's the instinct to reproduce and doing
dangerous shit has always gotten checks
and really that's what it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
how do you,
how do you account for chicks that like
getting hot air balloons and go across
the world.
How about this chick who's rolling her
way?
She's on a sail boat.
She's like 16 and she's sailing across
the ocean.
What's that about?
She's a lesbian.
She's trying to get some.
I don't know.
I mean I think that's some kind of,
you know,
some kind of tapping into the same.
Some of the same instincts.
I mean two lesbians trying to pick up
street chicks is just as creepy as dudes
trying to pick up straight checks.
My girl certainly gets her.
That's her fair share.
I was at the mailbox and I'm about
Senate package and this,
uh,
there's this lesbian lady and she's
like,
so obviously dykey just big and she's
got a mullet and it's,
it's,
it's like the whole deal right now and
she's got legs up going out of her way
and Eddie Bravo,
Falcon wristband.
It's like a leather strap on arrest and
the girl in front of her is a getting a
package,
you know,
and um,
uh,
she dropped something.
She was like,
Oh,
I'm sorry,
I'm so disorganized.
And the lesbian goes,
don't apologize for being human.
I was like,
oh,
it was so gross.
I literally put my hand up to my mouth.
I went like,
it was so like,
sleazy.
Here's my card,
you know,
it was so
like low rent,
you know,
traveling,
vacuum salesman,
trying to fuck somebody,
his wife,
you know what I mean?
It was like so sad.
Don't apologize for being late.
That must be what it sounds like.
You know,
when,
when dudes try to do it too,
I'm sure it is.
Yes.
It's the same thing,
right?
When you hear a dude with a sleazy
cheesy line,
you know,
and you're like,
oh,
you feel bad for that check or that
could be your sister,
that could be your daughter.
It's gonna.
Listen to this moron.
No,
I could always just give it to you right
here in my car.
It's brutal.
Oh yeah.
Could be someone's kid.
That perspective comes from having that
perspective.
Jacks you.
When you have children,
everything changes.
Porn becomes like a sad story,
you know,
like,
Oh,
poor girl getting fucked her.
That used to be somebody's baby.
Somebody's little girl used to be a
thumb now at some big giant Black Dick.
Glug,
glug.
She's getting gagged,
slapped in the face with it and went
wow.
Can enjoy it.
Not so fun.
Changed it.
Changed the game.
Have you been,
you've been Brian,
have you ever been to set up a porn
where a set of a porn?
Uh,
just like my bedroom and stuff like
that.
Now it goes.
Speaking of which,
um,
play your friend,
your friend's closet.
So this is not,
speaking of which I mean,
you really,
this is not a romantic situation for
some porn.
I filmed no same Tripoli's naughty show.
This is a video that I'm and tell
everybody they don't have to see it.
It's funny enough as it is,
but if you want to see it,
um,
what is the youtube address?
Uh,
it's just type in a little esther on the
street on a little esther on the street.
Now what this is,
is Brian's French is 20 to 22,
but she looks like she's 12.
Yeah.
Twelve years old.
Seriously.
She really looks like.
And that's her whole thing.
And she,
she was on Jimmy Kimmel.
She played Jimmy Kimmel's,
sister,
sister on a Jimmy Kimmel and in one
episode or so.
What is her name?
Uh,
esther.
Esther.
Yeah.
They,
they'll go by little esther.
She's hilarious.
She's like a new up and coming comic.
I would say that she does a lot of
comedy store stuff.
And Esther.
I'm sorry,
what's your last name again?
She goes by little esther.
Little Astro.
Yeah.
So you can find her.
Her name is,
uh,
is a mystery.
Well,
if you go on twitter,
it's twitter.com,
back slash L I l underscore,
I'll tweet it in a bit,
but uh,
yeah,
it's called a little effort and here's
a.
So how do you spell esther?
Hold on EST h e r o [inaudible].
I would have got that wrong.
So then I would have looked at it the
right way and be like,
that doesn't look right either.
Est He are,
they look stupid.
All right,
whatever.
Let's,
let's hear this.
It's funny,
she's on the street,
she's a,
she's a girl.
Literally,
he looks
like she's 12 years old and she's just
walking up to strangers and she's saying
that this is for her health class,
you know?
Yeah.
All right.
So here it goes.
She's got questions.
She needs the answers.
Interesting.
Um,
so I'm just asking questions,
right?
Teen Health Project.
What is friends with benefits mean?
Oh,
it's loading up.
It was loaded.
Oh,
that's so gay.
Brian.
I can't believe you did that.
It was loaded up earlier,
but you know,
you,
we went and did that.
Stopped it anyway,
blah,
blah.
Here.
Say it again.
They already heard that part,
God dammit.
Anyway,
that's really funny.
Yeah,
just go to online.
We'll play it in the bay or load up
while we're waiting.
Let it load up.
Okay.
Anyway,
she's 12 and she looks.
She looks.
She looks like she's 12.
It's really funny.
Video.
Yup.
From Sam Tripoli's.
Knotty show.
And she asked dirty questions.
Yeah,
a year and another joke.
Right.
But it's good.
It's a good joke.
It's very similar to that man show boy
concept kind of dirty kid.
Looks really young,
but tonight,
but we're more wrong because it's a
girl,
but at least it's a really.
She's really an adult as opposed to the.
Oh boy was a real little kid.
Was it?
I thought it.
I thought it wasn't.
I thought,
oh no,
no,
no.
I was a kid.
It was like he was like 15 or something.
It was a boy.
Right.
And he aged while the show was going on.
I didn't know that that became the man
show,
you know,
teenagers.
I always got that kid mixed up with Andy
meant millinocket or whatever his name
is.
I don't even know who Andy millinocket
says I know the name.
I've seen the name written in print and
it's like a cultural pop icon name.
Right.
I know someone will say it and I don't
know who it is.
I don't get it.
I've seen it 100 times.
Was pretty funny.
Any comic?
Yeah.
Well he's like,
like a video guy that he didn't.
I don't even know,
like a youtube,
a youtube,
that kind of.
But he also has been in like stuff,
you know,
movies and people don't get offended
when you say they don't know who they
are and there's just so many,
many people to know from MTV.
I think Korea too much shit going on,
man.
I can't keep up with those God damn
videos.
People are sending me.
I look at my twitter.
It's like if I,
if I wanted to just waste my entire
life,
not waste but use up all my time,
I would just go on my twitter and watch
all the videos of people send me all
these fucked up crazy videos over and
over and over and over again all day.
Check this out.
Oh my God,
have you ever seen this?
How is this guy still alive?
Who Do it everyday?
Animal attacks,
car wrecks,
motorcycle crash animal.
All fucking day.
Dude.
So much content out there.
It's impossible to watch it all.
You're our minds.
You being reprogrammed.
You sit in front of these fucking
computers.
You just inundated with crazy shit over
and over again all day.
If you have time,
if you have time and your Dick Works,
someone's going to say to you something
fucked up,
right?
Because if you have time and you're
young enough to be having fun in life,
you're gonna.
Have some fun friends and if you have
fun friends,
they're going to see some fucked up
shit.
If they're going to see some fucked up
shit,
then I want you to see it too.
Right?
Right.
If it tweaks,
they're going to want to send
it to you.
They want to.
They're going to want to be the one that
shocks you.
It's too much,
man.
It is.
It's,
you know,
every once in a while just reading a
book with actual pages,
you know,
because I got the ipad thing and that.
I like that too,
you know,
but it's sometimes comforting.
Go back a page of letters.
You've tried this recently and this was
a big thing that I do is a sensory
deprivation tank.
You just tried it for the first time,
right?
Yep.
And what did you,
uh,
what'd you think about that?
I think I sent this to you in an email,
but I likened it to the first time I had
sex,
like I could tell it was something rad
and I knew I was going to dig it for the
most the rest of my life,
but I was terrible at it.
Like just not quite good at it yet,
you know,
you have to really just relax your mind.
And I was fidgeting with how comfortable
I was,
but then I also was super tired when I,
when I was in there,
you know,
it was a long week and I didn't have it,
available to me except for you know,
kind of late in the evening.
And I wanted to make sure I got in so I
started to fall asleep,
but it was just crazy consciousness and
asleep,
sleep like I saw this window of where
sleep was and I could visually see it,
I could see it with my eyes open and I
could crawl in it and I was asleep and I
could crawl out of it and not be asleep
and I was fully in control of,
of how it was going and that was pretty.
That was pretty wild.
I mean what you're able to do with your
mind in that situation where you can't
tell when your eyes are open and your
eyes are closed and there's no feeling,
no sensation on your body.
The amount of control I was able to
exercise was amazing.
It didn't find any kind of great lucid
information out of it,
but the experience was wild.
I mean,
I've never been able to see those layers
because usually you just pass out.
You don't know when you fell asleep,
all of a sudden you're awake.
You remember that.
Then all of a sudden you're asleep and
you wake up the next morning,
but this.
I was able to see the steps in between.
He never realized how quiet it is until
the power goes out in your house.
You know when the power goes out in the
neighborhood and the power's out
everywhere that you hear things go off
and is that that dead silence that you
don't get any other way while the tank?
Is that times a million?
Yup.
Tank is that with your body?
It shuts everything off everything.
It's.
It's one of the things that I always
talk about.
I talk about on this podcast all the
time.
I talk about in interviews all the time
and the thing that I'm,
oh,
I always say is that I'm.
I'm always shocked that people don't do
this.
I'm always shocked that people don't
know about this.
I'm shocked that there's not one of
these on every corner that people aren't
having these things put in their house.
They have Jacuzzi to put in their house.
Why don't you have an isolation tank?
Like do you not want to be happy?
Do you not want to think?
You don't want to relax.
People are running like hell from their
own thoughts.
That's too dangerous.
Too much work,
man.
That's too much work.
It's more work to to run for Miss Shit
than it is to face your shit,
you know,
and that there's no face in your shit.
Like facing your shit in that tank.
Yep.
When you can't hide behind any bullshit,
when you're in there,
you're,
there's no distractions,
there's nothing you get right
immediately to the whatever it was
fucking with you.
Anything.
And then once you get good at that,
then you become a I,
he become an astral traveler.
You get in there and you,
you learn how to,
how to really let go lock in quick.
I couldn't lock.
I lock in within 15 minutes,
I'm gone.
I settle in.
I it always.
The thing is you always got to get your
body to relax.
There's so much carrying around and you
don't realize how much tension you have
in you until you in a zero gravity
environment and you realize you're
holding yourself.
You're like pulling yourself in like
your back muscles are pulled in your
arms and pulling.
You don't even realize you're doing
this.
You're like fighting the world all the
time,
but when you get in there and then all
that shit goes away.
Then about 15 minutes and once the
breathing stabilizes and I go that I'm
gone.
Then I'm often the land of wild
hallucinations and fucking vivid dreams
and lucid dreaming and flying and uh,
communicating with entities and having
things explained to you in gigantic
three dimensional numbers from an alien
planet that are rotating around you and
some big hall,
a scope that's like,
like a,
like a hologram that shaped like the
planet earth.
I was watching the universe being
explained to me in letters that were
from another planet that we're spinning
around that were three dimensional and
it was all being orchestrated by these
aliens.
And it made sense to me while I was
watching it.
I was trying to figure out their code
and their patterns.
This is okay.
So this is how the whole universe works.
It all works.
But this one thing.
Then everything goes into another thing.
And that goes deeper and deeper and
deeper and deeper.
That's how crazy the ticket.
Yep.
Why is that?
Not Everywhere.
Well,
I mean there's other ways to get there,
right?
There ain't no other way to get there
unless you're doing drugs.
Right,
exactly.
That's kind of where I was leading to.
I mean,
but there's.
But even those are better in the tank.
Yeah.
Mushrooms in the tank or a totally
different animal man.
There's no distractions.
That mushroom gets to talk right to you.
You know the weed in the tank,
the weeds talking right to you.
There's no,
oh my ass is on the couch and the light
is hitting my eyes and the elbow touches
the seat arm.
There's none of that.
There's no input.
There's so many powerful weapons at our
disposal that people are so scared of.
I mean,
it's just crazy.
the tank is one of them,
obviously a huge resource and it's easy.
It's just,
you know,
you can't complain about anything.
But then there's other shamans for
years.
I think the best way I've heard it
described as as rad book or the cosmic
serpent by Jeremy and and he says,
the Shamans goal is to lead you to the
realm of the spirit,
then allow you to defolk focalized.
He talks about it like a stereo.
Graham,
you remember those three d images where
you know,
you relax your eyes and they,
the three d would pop out.
He's like,
that's what you're doing when you're in
that kind of shamanistic experiences,
your [inaudible] your body and then
allowing communication to come through
and hit.
But his theories are pretty amazing.
I mean it's just these conversations
are.
There's people right now that are
listening.
Okay.
And there's two groups of people that
obviously there's more than two,
but when it comes to this subject,
there's people who've had psychedelic
experiences and people who have no
fucking idea what we're talking about.
Like literally you think we're talking
about hippy fairy dust,
you know,
like this is what it sounds like.
You're,
wait a minute,
what are you doing?
You're tuning in to what he had to it
in,
into what do you.
Yeah,
you're tuning into Santa Claus,
what's going on,
right.
Like there's like there's even
intelligent scientists that we'll have
conversations and if you bring up any
sort of psychedelic or any sort of
psychedelic compound or altered states
of consciousness,
they just shut off on you.
They just immediately discredit
everything you're saying.
Well,
you're just talking about getting high
and muscles.
Well,
you know,
nice little box that they can and they
toss it away,
but if they've done mushrooms,
they'll go,
oh yeah,
they'll look at you and go,
yeah,
it might be that.
Yeah,
it might be that I've talked to like
some serious,
serious fucking scientists,
men and guys who have phds and guys who
work at universities teaching schools
and any teaching physics courses and
shit.
I've talked to them about psychedelics
and add some fascinating conversations
where people who are way smarter than
me,
way more educated than me,
way,
way more experienced in the ways of the
world and they've had a bunch of
psychedelic experiences and you know,
they'll tell you like,
who knows what that is?
Yeah.
Who the fuck knows what that.
That might be a billion different
things.
This is a pretty cool theory by Jeremy
and rob,
and I'll give you the cliff notes here,
so for discussion sake,
but he went down to the Ios garrow
Charmaine's down in the jungle and I
took the Iowasca with them and he was
just an anthropologist just for people
who don't know.
Let's explain what Iowasca is.
IOWASCA is two different plants.
There's the actual dimethyltryptamine
active plant that is part of a vine and
then somehow out of the 80,000
species in the Amazon,
they figured out things.
It's other than that,
yeah,
there's this other leaf that they needed
to combine with it to actually make it
work and a Mao inhibitor.
So they combine this and they make it
into a tea and it's been part of the
traditional religious ceremonies down
there.
Yeah.
So what does dmt stuff is is a chemical
that it's the most potent psychedelic
drug known to man,
but it exists in a bunch of different
plants,
but you can't eat it because when you
eat it,
it exists in so many different things.
I guess your body has some protection
for because if you eat grass,
grass has dmt in it,
well there's a thing that your stomach
makes called Mano aiming oxidation.
That's Mao.
So these guys figured out how to mix an
Mao inhibitor that kills the Mao in
their system with this dmt so that they
can take it orally and you talk to
owners when they interviewed the guys
and they asked them how they figured
this shit out thousands of years ago,
by the way,
they said the plants,
that's how they say about all the
medicines that they,
the plants.
So Jeremy,
he took that and he was like,
how could this be true?
He's like,
science discredits it,
but they prove it time and
time again.
They pick the shit that works.
And then modern Pharma goes down there
and say,
Hey,
what does this do?
And they know the answer.
So how do they know the answers?
You know?
And so the theory is that this all comes
from your brain,
your brain projects,
this stuff when you take
dimethyltryptamine.
But he has a different theory and his
theory goes that,
you know,
in all of these cultures you see a lot
of serpents when you're underneath these
visions and these serpents are often
intertwined and you can see this written
in in rock paintings,
in aboriginal Australia and all over the
place.
The vision of the serpent,
he calls it the cosmic serpent is
everywhere.
And what he's saying is that's actually
a vision of person's DNA,
of DNA in general,
not just the person,
but the DNA of life and that you're
actually,
when you're in that level,
you're communicating on a
microbiological level with DNA,
which is connects everything.
It's kind of like the Navi avatar
principle where everything is connected
by the universal language of DNA and the
default realization of the IOWASCA
allows you to communicate with the DNA
so that the plants talk to you,
that there's visions and wisdom from
everything that comes and the synthesis
is able to get.
I mean,
there's actually DNA emits and one of
the ways you say they communicate is DNA
emits actual light.
It emits photons.
DNA itself will do that.
It's too dim and it's too small when you
isolate DNA by itself,
but it'll emit a certain amount of
photons.
So you know the,
all of these theories that you know,
your beings of light and whatever and
everything's all.
Everything is light.
Oh,
sounds like you said,
like hippie stuff or whatever.
But it's cross culturally.
People say this.
Well when you do Dmt,
that's what you see.
Two,
you see beings that are may not have
light.
Right?
Exactly.
And he's saying that's the DNA.
The DNA is the substance of life.
It's interconnected substance of life.
And that's,
that's basically the collective
unconscious,
you know,
and that's how all different life
I see where you're doing,
you're just trying to fuck.
And there's always the cynic those steps
in.
Yeah,
that's good.
You've got,
this is what you got.
You've got chemicals interacting with
your brain and you'd go loopy for a few
hours while your body tries to normalize
the poison you've put in your system.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What you are.
Okay,
it's just another religion,
man.
You're just believe in some more wacky
shit.
And all that one ever tells me is that
dude hasn't done dmt.
That's all it tells me.
If you're talking shit about doing DMT,
for sure you haven't done it.
Because once you do it you go,
oh,
oh Whoa,
whoa.
Really,
really changes the game.
And these guys have been doing it for
thousands of years and people go,
what we'll do through so's book smart
man a bit.
Have TVS or cars didn't have paved
roads.
Because if you are doing dmt all the
time,
you wouldn't give a fuck about tvs.
TV Ain't shit compared to being able to
communicate with the afterlife.
You fuck you.
You know what's funny?
I can fish.
I'll go get a fish.
It takes me an hour.
I cook,
I know I have food,
I'm done.
I'll go do some more.
Tay,
right?
The ios cares,
they call,
they call the Iowaska,
but the television of the forest,
that's what they call it.
Like that is,
that is where they go to the interesting
point.
Are there any television?
They brought some Iowasca back from,
uh,
from Brazil.
I believe this was in the fifties.
And they,
when they first recognize it as a
psychoactive substance,
they were going to call it telepathy
because it allowed group think and
allowed to let pathy,
like they were going to pat it as
telepathy,
but they didn't realize that the,
um,
one of the active compounds in it had
already been identified and that was
harming and because harming had already
been identified because of the rules of
scientific nomenclature,
like the thing they were naming had
already been named.
So they couldn't call it telepathy,
but that's what they were going to call
it.
They were going to call it telepathy.
Been like,
Whoa,
that's the active ingredient or
something that allows you to have
telepathy.
This is really like,
scientists are fucking writing this
down.
Right?
That's nutty shit man.
It sounds so woo.
Deepak Chopra,
yoga beads bullshit.
It sounds so fucking dumb to me.
It sounds dumb,
but I know it's real because I've done
it like that's how crazy dmt is.
An IOWASCA and mushrooms and all these
things that people just automatically
label as silly automat.
These are life changing reset button
pressing motherfuckers.
And everybody's like,
oh,
what are you doing?
Mushrooms,
man.
Here's an honest question.
Do you talk about DMT everyday?
Is there days that you don't talk about
it?
Not at all.
So amazing that like it's just flooding.
Can't talk about anything every day.
Man.
I Bet I think about it every day.
There's always a moment where I'm like
in the shower by myself and go,
Oh yeah,
so you don't think that's kind of crazy
that you're not crazy.
It's just like if you were picked up by
God and take on a magical mystery tour
for three hours,
the spaceship above fucking Pluto view
would be remembering that shit all the
time because it was the most extreme
experience a human being could ever
possibly have felt that like in drugs
where I'm like,
this is the most amazing thing in the
whole entire group,
but I don't think.
Not like that.
You don't like that.
It's not.
This was the most amazing thing in the
world.
It's not like that at all.
It's this,
that this is even possible,
is impossible.
That this exists is mind blowing,
that this reality seems really than the
reality that I live in every day.
The fact that there's something that
feels like it's communicating with you
and it's giving you a message that
you're connected to everything and that
it's a gigantic illusion created by your
biology to keep you alive and to make
you sustain this other world that exists
in your dream consciousness.
I mean they,
they communicate this shit to you and it
makes sense and whatever it is is sees
right through you and communicates only
with love and is showing you impossible
to believe.
Images and visuals and at the end of it,
when it's all over,
you're changed forever.
Like you can never get to go back on,
go back.
You want to,
but you couldn't anyway,
but you've got to make sure that
whatever you get out of that,
you can still talk to people.
That's another much of anything.
Like,
I don't want to lose your grip.
Yeah,
you don't want to get slippery,
slippery.
You could get.
If you know,
there's a guy that I know that's a
tattoo artist that's done dmt like 100
times and um,
I,
I have hung out with this dude and he
did Eddie's arm know Eddie's a sleeve.
I don't want to say his name just in
case he doesn't want people knowing.
Anyway,
dude is got this fucking sniper stare.
He's got this look in his eyes,
man.
Like he's just been over there just a
few too many times.
Like he can't ever quite step back into
the real world.
Like every corner he turns around,
there's fucking DMT.
Elves stared at him from behind the
counter.
Like he's just been there too many
times.
Man.
He's had some very interesting.
He doesn't talk about it.
That's a weird thing I think when you,
when you,
when he does talk about it,
but he doesn't go into depth like me,
like I'm just yapping about it because I
haven't done it in years.
So it's still fresh in my mind.
It,
it start off like I'm talking about it a
lot and then you start peeing your pants
and then we can talk about it.
You start seeing it again,
like little flashbacks will pop into
your head of things that happened,
not flashbacks,
like you were like you can't see or
you're hallucinating,
but just like,
oh yeah.
Oh,
okay.
That happened.
Oh yeah.
Just,
just.
It makes you think about it again.
There was one experience that,
uh,
that I had at the traditional shaman out
in,
uh,
out in the desert here in the US.
And she took me out.
She took me out a girl Shama yeah,
female.
She's hardcore and uh,
and so with the music start.
So,
but anyways,
I,
you know,
I fasted for traditional preparation and
I drank,
drank,
drank of substance.
I think it was,
um,
you know,
some kind of mushroom and other
traditional plant based substance.
And that what I got from that has
totally changed my life forever.
At that point I was able to lift from my
body,
lift from it,
look down and realize,
Oh wow,
this is just the vessel,
you know,
it's useful.
It's wonderful.
It allows me to flow through this world,
but it's not the end of.
It's not the beal,
you know,
like there's a separation.
There is a distinction between body and
spirit and from then the fear of death
evaporated for me and it's just.
It would just be a shame.
Like I certainly don't want to die.
I love life.
Life is fucking rat,
but the fear of it is gone.
There was just a loose nation,
man.
You were on mushrooms.
You're hanging out with a hot shaman
girl trying to get some pussy.
You got a little carried up in the
moment.
You went a little barry manilow.
She's just.
Just put him on your shoulders,
man.
He could have been January shoulder.
Everything of that.
Do you ever.
Do you know the book of the,
of the book,
Sacred Mushroom in the cross?
You ever heard that story?
I've heard a little bit about John Marco
Allegro,
who was the one of the head scholars of
the Dead Sea Scrolls.
He was in charged of deciphering it.
Spent 14 years working on the oldest
version of the Bible by far and what he
decided after 14 years,
he wrote a book about it that the entire
Christian religion was a gigantic
misunderstanding.
What it was initially all about was
psychedelic mushrooms and fertility
rituals and he said,
this is what the whole Christian
religion was initially all about and
like,
you know,
has this fucking book dedicated to it.
I don't know.
I can't follow it.
I don't understand,
you know,
ancient languages.
I have no knowledge,
but just the fact that this guy was
really well respected scholar and it
came to these conclusions.
I mean,
of course they were doing drugs.
The drugs were around.
Mushrooms have been around for thousands
and thousands of years.
What were the first ones to figure out?
You can eat it.
People back then ate everything they
could write.
They had everything.
They had a truck.
The reason why we know shit's poisonous
is because due to eight it and died and
then they said,
all right,
he ate that.
He'd died.
Don't eat that.
You read that.
You try eating that because if this is,
there's a lot of this shit around it.
This is edible.
It's good,
it's good.
The apples are good.
Let's eat the apples.
That mean that's how they figured out
how to do things.
They ate everything,
Bro.
They it all.
They knew what was good,
what was bad,
and if mushrooms are around and they
were people were eating them and if
people were eating them,
they were seeing God and if they were
seeing God,
they didn't want anybody else in on the
action.
So what do they do?
They hid all their fucking knowledge
about these mushrooms and these rituals
and they put it in stories and they put
it in fables and parables and they just
twisted it all up so it was just a
little bit different.
Yeah.
Fascinating.
That's the fucking.
The forbidden fruit is a mushroom man.
That's what it is.
I mean there's,
there's an ancient fresco in France,
there's this ancient.
I'm a painting rather,
and it's a on a,
on this wall.
It's from fucking thousands of years ago
and it's Adam and eve with a mushroom
tree is Adam and eve with mushroom caps
all around them.
I mean it is the fucking forbidden fruit
and it's been squashed because if you
take that,
that's a direct link I feel to God,
you know,
I'm a both a spiritual person in a kind
of a deistic believer in the,
in the universal God for us.
But you take,
so you take away mushrooms and then you
insert people and people get to absolve
you of your sins.
It gives them power.
You build them giant structures,
you know,
they get the hat,
we'll money power and if you look at the
history of the Catholic Church,
women as well,
especially in the Middle Ages and the
renaissance going through there and so
they have inserted themselves and then
removed the other mechanism to get there
directly.
So they become the intermediaries at a
certain point.
I wonder,
I mean how much of that is true because
there's a lot of speculation about,
you know,
we're,
where they lost the way and what it was
really all about.
I'm wondering how much they let the
common people know about it.
Even back then,
you know,
maybe it was something that,
the,
the elite found out about it and they
tried to protect the information even
from the common folk,
but also might have been a question of
climate change to terence.
Mckenna's had some ideas about that and
he thought that,
um,
with the global climate change,
which is,
you know,
very cyclical happens all the time.
A lot of times the climate will be
inhospitable for mushrooms that changes.
So instead of getting mushrooms all the
time,
now they can't get them anymore.
And so then the culture completely
changes and becomes more of an alcohol
based culture starts off.
They start using preserved,
uh,
mushrooms in honey because we know
they've been preserving things in honey
for and thousands of years.
And then you deal with fermentation
because honey can become a psychoactive
substance on its own.
It could become mead.
When it becomes fermented,
it becomes like an alcohol.
And so then they go into an alcohol
culture.
And then before you know it,
the mushroom ideas are gone all the
love.
And you know,
all the,
your fellow man that Shit's out the
window and now you know,
everyone's just drunk and raping.
You know,
it's interesting.
It's fascinating shit man.
What you always got to wonder like how
did we get to be who we are now?
Like what was it like?
Could you imagine if you could go to
like 1400 BC and just go hang around
England and see what the fuck was going
on in France and see how people were
living in Europe.
You know?
How trippy would that be?
Man,
that'd be crazy.
Woo.
That would be the strangest fucking
thing to be able to go back in time.
Even just in like an invisible,
impenetrable capsule.
Like you could just stand there like in
an invisible phone booth in the middle
of a town,
you know?
And you get to watch and they can't walk
through the phone booth.
It looks like a tree.
They can't touch it.
You know?
I've always,
I've been fascinated by that moment
before battle,
you know,
where you know,
you just have,
you have like an ax or you choose
between an ax,
a morning star and a sword and you're
like,
what am I going to use?
It's gonna maybe make me survive,
you know,
like how good is my armor?
Not as good as that dude's but I'm a
rocket anyways.
And like just feel that.
I mean mma gets an approximation of that
and I think why people love it so much
because it's the closest we got,
but it pales in comparison to that,
you know,
to that moment you're with all of the
people in your country and perhaps the
horde that's coming is going to rape
your girl,
you know,
kill your children,
put them into slavery,
smash their head on and you got it.
You just got to fucking hold the ground,
you know,
like how is that?
We don't even know what that's about.
I have no idea.
No,
and they did that forever.
Forever.
I mean that was such a part of the
human,
you know,
birthright.
But how much of that shit is still in
our genes and how do you shut that shit
of it?
All right.
The human hardware is so retro still
goes on now like any war,
you're doing the same thing.
Like what kind of missiles is this guy
goes different now.
It's totally impersonal.
You know?
It's so impersonal.
Know with the call of duty,
it's pretty great.
Soldiers were saying just said call of
duty.
Well two wars are going overseas.
What that means like call of duty.
That means it's all ground game.
That game is pretty much ground game
going into or explosions and stuff like
that.
Still going on for is
going on and you know what else is going
on?
Drones.
Drones are allowed to go into places
we're not even really at war with.
Like in Pakistan,
we're not really supposed to be a war in
Pakistan,
but we got spaceships that are working
on remote control from Nevada.
They're remote controlling them from
Nevada and jacking dudes in Pakistan
from the air.
It
probably have iphone apps with
controlling.
Just tilt it man.
You can destroy that person by just
hitting.
Do it.
It's like that movie.
Do you remember that movie where the
dude got really good at that video game
and then the aliens came and recruited
him?
Yeah,
I remember that Shit.
Star Star fighter starfighter.
Was that it?
Starfighter.
I just remember because his name was
Rogan.
His name was Alex Rogan and you know
dude,
I mean they're doing that with kids that
get really good at video games,
man.
Yeah.
Kids get real good at video games.
You guys are awesome.
Already hasn't been score and then
people burst in your dorm.
Pneumatics on the army has a video game
that's tracked so they can track the top
guys.
I bet those top guys get knocks on the
door of once in a while.
Would you like a million dollars?
You imagine that you would like to add
pounds and you're in your underwear.
You like,
um.
I don't like killing things for real.
It just make to play your game.
Can I go back to playing your game?
You put some poor little 13 year old,
like flat boat years.
You can join us.
You can play that game for a living.
What do you think?
Bell tell anything you want.
Take some poor fucking kid.
It was just awesome.
At the army game.
Yeah.
It's scary to remove that personal side
to killing.
I mean it's just a totally different
paradigm.
When we were talking before the show
about these guys that had been caught in
Afghanistan that are US soldiers that
had been killing civilians and taking
home little trophies.
They'd been playing like a game just
jacking people and killing people.
Just they get to use to killing people,
man.
To,
to used to killing people and to use to
being in a place where everyone presents
you and they don't want you to be there.
You know?
I always,
for the longest time I always would look
at,
at like politicians and go,
how much say do they really have?
How much state is a president really
have and what the fuck is going on over
there?
Or is he just a dude with a job just
like all of us.
Is it just all bullshit once you get in
there,
you know,
and I used to look at Bush and when,
when Bush was in Iraq and I say,
how is this motherfucker responsible for
all these people dying?
Is he responsible for all this talk
about weapons of mass destruction or is
he just some dude who's got to do this
job?
And I remember when he was standing in
front of those people and that dude took
off his shoes and through madam.
Yeah,
I remember that Shit.
I remember that and he ducked and then
to do through it again and he ducked
again and he had a little half smile on
his face and I'm like,
that guy's just a spokesman.
Yeah,
that's what I got out of that.
I looked at that.
I'm like,
that is just a dude with a very
difficult job that's not all that bright
and has some ideals and got stuck in
this situation and yeah,
he's got to say we're going to war,
but there's a machine behind that
motherfucker.
He's not running.
Shit I'm looking at is duck in those
shoes smiling?
I'm like,
that guy is not.
He doesn't have a care in the world.
He's not worrying about what happened in
Iraq.
He's.
He says,
no,
he's just an employee.
Perhaps it's not as responsibility,
really,
is it?
I don't know.
I think Alex Jones would have a theory
on that.
That was my favorite part of the whole
Bush administration was in that through
through the shoes.
It was the first time I liked him.
The first time I liked Bush,
I would get angry.
I'm like,
this mother fucker's just bake it a
board.
It's all bullshit now.
I thought about.
I'm like,
that guy probably gets like four hours
sleep a night.
What would I be saying if I was speaking
all these people,
I'd be making up words too.
I'd be stumbling.
I'd fuck my words up at it.
Everybody fucks up.
You know.
Obama said something about there being
48 states.
I mean,
he fucked up the states when he was
running.
You know,
people fuckings up all the time.
You're not thinking you're tired all the
time.
You're on this campaign trail.
They don't.
He's not running shit.
I learned like Bush.
No,
I mean I think he's probably right.
It's probably not a bad guy.
Okay.
Everybody's like use the gym and he's
double.
I bet they believe that you're really a
president until they get in there.
You know?
I think once you get in there,
you,
they open up these doors and you get to
see the gears of the universe run.
You get to see the gears of our whole
system and the fucking.
Well,
if we stopped the war,
we don't have the oil and we needed to
do in society is going to fall apart and
we're getting to a point of
overpopulation.
That's why you need to feed them in
camps and we have to make sure that if
something goes down,
we have enough caskets and whoa now
about you cutting taxes.
Oh fuck.
All that.
Fuck all that.
Exactly.
We don't need some money,
dude.
We're going to need some money or some
shit going on.
We've got to come up with an alternative
fuel.
We have exactly two years worth of fuel
left and then people start eating
people.
Okay,
what the fuck happens when you get in
there,
man?
Yeah.
I was a big,
big support.
I was a big Obama Fan.
I thought,
you know,
maybe I don't.
I'm not.
I'm a libertarian so I'm not Republican
or Democrat,
but I thought this dude is smart.
He can hoop.
He's got a good family.
It looks like he'll get in there and
play a little basketball.
Hey,
you say that I,
I appreciate it.
I saw him play pool.
They'll go,
this guy's got gotta look,
Bama can get out.
You mean for balls on the table?
Obama might get out on man played halo.
Reach with him.
He's a regular dude.
That's what I want.
I don't want something fucking child
blood sucking dragon like Dick Cheney.
Dick Cheney can't play pool.
He's too busy killing people.
You think Dick Cheney everland had to
play basketball.
No,
he's heart explodes when he tries to tie
his shoes at 150 heart attacks,
you know he ain't playing shit with you
and he's got no sense of humor.
You know,
I,
I could recognize him and relate to him
more than anyone that has ever been
president before.
I was like,
well,
here's a guy who was only a few years
older than me,
and he seems like a normal dude.
You know,
like Kanye West.
He calls him a jackass and like,
yeah,
fuck yeah,
this is his wife.
It's like,
oh yeah.
He kissed his wife.
That bullshit.
Quail.
That was carrie.
Oh,
all of them.
All of them.
My favorite swarmy Douche bag busted
you.
You fucking fake all of them,
man.
It's like you can't.
It's like,
it's impossible to be honest.
It's impossible to do it.
They won't let you get in.
You got to be full of shit to get in.
I thought Obama was the first guy that
wasn't full of Shit.
I was like,
what is.
He seems like soda can take a chance
with.
I was,
I was backing.
I think you can do anything.
I think you get in.
It's just a stalemated yeah.
You get in.
It's just like,
well fuck you.
No lobbyists and fucking congress and
this and that and layers and red tape
and chaos and war,
and then they just tell her when heroin,
heroin,
heroin coming in by the fucking
boatload.
What's the heroin doing?
It's just slightly.
Afghans need to make a profit.
Otherwise support this war.
You know?
We were talking about that on the Alex
Jones show.
We were talking about that before the
show that there was a Geraldo Rivera was
in Afghanistan talking to this fucking
soldier,
this guy who has a family who is
supposed to be defending his country and
meanwhile where is he?
He's in the poppy fields protecting the
poppy fields for the afghany farmers
because in order for the Afghan farmers
to support the fact that we're over in
Afghanistan dropping bombs on your moms,
we have to get this guy's approval and
we have to allow them to keep producing
their illegal crop of heroin.
So we have American soldiers that are
guarding Afghanistan heroin so that we
can go over there and blow shit up.
God Damn.
What do you do if your Obama,
what do you do?
Fuck.
You get into how you gonna fix that.
It's tough,
but as you know,
I think they figured out that his
approval ratings were dropping as the
economy was tightening up and so they're
like,
ah,
fuck it.
Let's just put some more money on the
system,
push the ball up,
and then it's working.
If I thought that heroin was helping the
economy,
I would say so that heroin,
who the fuck is buying heroin retards?
You know,
why is oil still like in,
at least in California?
Most states right now,
still cheap.
Cheaper than it was like five years ago.
And you know what you mean?
When Bush was leaving office then they
had a fucking a grab,
but don't you say,
why don't you think it should be like
ridiculously high,
especially after that spill and stuff
like that.
Well,
did you just realize or just here
rather,
they underestimated Iraqis oil reserve
by 25 percent.
There's 25 percent more oil in Iraq and
they thought there was a.
oh Shit,
oh shit,
I'm gonna.
Get that quote that son fuck a Va.
You know,
listen man,
who the fuck knows?
I think it was,
I think they just jacked up all the
prices that they can pay for new plaza
on top of the all the fucking oil.
You got to be gotten to like the gas
station.
There's like nice plasma tvs and
everything like that and like how does,
where does this come from?
Oh yeah,
$5 a gallon last last year.
You know,
I'm,
I'm wondering who actually,
how that works.
I think.
I think actually how it works is the.
I mean they're all in bed together
obviously,
but I believe it's the distributors that
set the price and then these oil
companies,
like there's a place up the street,
it's owned by these hindus that I go to
and they have like the ohm on the door.
I'm like,
this is the oddest place ever.
They sell weed pipes.
They're there.
So we pipes and incense at the counter.
Like this is the oddest place ever.
Like you guys sell petrochemicals.
You sell,
you know the real problem,
the reason why we're in war,
that you know the reason why we pollute
and it's all coming out of this hole
right here.
And then you get the oam at the door.
So I don't think it's them setting the
price of the plasmas.
I think it's the companies that sell it
to them,
you know,
it's all for free market speculation,
handles a lot of that.
I mean,
when oil price was dropping there as big
deflationary pressures,
at the same time,
gold prices were dropping,
things were priced because nobody had
any money.
The speculators weren't able to buy the
gold,
they were pulling their assets back out
into cash,
et cetera.
But now things are a little bit looser
and these commodities have value.
They're more worried about inflation now
because obama's push it,
you know,
just shoving money into the system.
So in an inflationary time then these
commodities have value.
So now we're seeing oil rising.
We're seeing gold bush.
I would,
there was one big jump where it went up
to like five bucks a gallon.
What was the cause of that?
I,
you know,
I think at that point it was the massive
inflationary concern,
you know,
that there was,
that money was goIng to lose its value
and that caused the oil to go up in
price at the.
Yeah.
When it,
when it goes up a barrel,
does anybody know?
You don't know either.
Do you?
Brian has no idea.
Yeah,
it's fine.
I'll tell you.
It's dangerous.
It's ninja set the price in Japan on
friendly dolphins and there's certain,
there's certain supply and demand
factors involved in the oil but as well
specifically,
but on a macro level,
I mean it's all about generally
inflation.
It just seemed very suspicious to me
that it was the end of the bush
administration and administration that
was clearly under the influence of big
oil and then at the very end of the
administration,
everything just gets
delta twist to pay his tab.
You know?
It was true,
it was true red line.
They were going to red line as much
money out of the system as they could
until the new administration came into
play on how much,
how much control does the president or
the administration really have and how
that kind of stuff works.
Do they have any at all?
It's all gotta be set up.
There's no way they're going let some
new dude come in every four years and
just rerun shit like why would we do
that?
We know the career guys,
the very top of the heap.
They've already.
We got this.
We got no.
Well opec supposedly sets how much the
available reserves there are and kind of
does that,
but how much is it?
You know,
all of that is speculation now who knows
how much they know and what they're
doing,
but it's.
It's an interesting game with a lot of
money at stake when you have that much
money at stake,
you could be buck sure that people are
trying to figure out a way to fuck it.
You know?
It's pretty amazing what it's done now
because if it wasn't for oil,
there would be no plastic.
There'd be no computers,
it'd be no nothing.
You know,
all the shit that we make today.
No flashlights,
no flashlights.
Especially flashlight is actually made
out of oil.
This shit has to come out of the ground
as oil before you can fuck it.
Yeah.
Mostly mineral oil,
food grade,
mineral,
a primary component
and food grade mineral oil comes out of
the ground,
right?
Just like,
just like,
well
why?
Where does it mean?
Doesn't it all come from?
Yeah.
I think it actually might come from it.
Probably know
that doesn't come from fish.
Can you make a flashlight?
That official.
Al will be nasty.
That would be more realistic.
Dirty fucking deep flashlight.
Maybe some dudes just missed stinky
pussy.
All the only time they got laid as by
slots and just drunk pigs and that's
what gives me a hard on.
There's a good mood.
There's a product that came out actually
called the vulva and what they've done,
they sell it for 40 bucks,
gagging already 40 bucks and it's like a
little perfume vial that supposedly
smells like pussy.
So obviously being in the business that
we ordered some fast around a smell and
it doesn't quite get there,
but what it kind of smells like is like
a cat.
No,
no,
it's way closer to that.
It's like post condoms,
sweaty sex,
sweat and rubber has like this.
Like this.
Oh,
why would anybody want to sell stinky
pussy smell?
I dunno.
We used to send ours with,
with like knife to spread on your
vanilla scent.
But now all flashlights come on.
So I always wonder how much fart porn is
just for show how much of dudes who are
mostly definitely girls who were foreign
and dudes miles and they're beating off
and shit.
What,
what is that?
Is that for show or is that just fire
porn really over the deep end.
What is that?
Uh,
you know,
I,
I think with all these fetishes out
there likes it for sure.
At least familiar for sure.
He's one guy out there,
loves every,
you know what I think it is.
I think all of these fetishes,
whether their feet or whether it's shit,
I think someone's mommy was like,
that's disgusting.
Don't you ever fart like bottle and they
just hammer them with this repression
and this repression gets all twisted up
and then all of a sudden all they want
to do to get a boner is barred on
somebody because they've been told by
their mothers so many times.
Parting is disgusting.
Don't ever fart.
And I think the same with feet,
like hide your dirty feet,
you're dirty feet day,
they think blah blah blah and like
really like kind of victorian,
you know,
parents are doing.
Then all of a sudden all they want to do
is see someone getting jerked off by
girls feet.
So what's your I,
you know,
I don't have one really bright girl.
I don't know.
My beautiful girlfriend friend.
Yeah.
What's your spine?
I have a lot of fetishes.
Really?
Yeah,
totally.
Definitely boobs.
That's not a.
So it's called being a dude now.
Every guys in the boobs,
I'm not really.
No,
you don't remember,
but my mom really a bug guy,
but it's definitely more.
I appreciate,
I appreciate what they do to the
feminine form.
Like I can aesthetically value them,
but as a sexual object very low on the
list.
Yeah,
I agree.
Well,
I don't say they're low on the list,
but they do not compare it to the ass.
This is critical.
It's very important that trigger girl
can have a tremendous ass and really be
like an a cop and she's hot as fuck.
You know?
It doesn't matter.
You look at the ash like,
god damn.
Yeah,
but girl with big tits
and a really flat ass.
It's just like if the bud had nipples,
I would agree.
If the fns had nipples,
Could you imagine though,
if an asset,
if that'd be the nipples,
you would agree that you don't want to
fly one.
No,
I'm just saying for fed is,
is if you combined boob and asked,
that would be like the best.
Do a mashup.
Yeah.
I want to finish refinish mashup.
The remix.
It.